[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning only
on cbs this morning former first lady
michelle obama
is unveiling the next step in her effort
to get more families access to healthy
food
she discusses her newest initiative with
waffles and mochi
in our next hour i just love this
picture i can't wait to hear more about
this
they are the stars of her netflix show
that teaches kids about
new foods and culinary traditions well
we spoke with mrs obama about food
insecurity and other challenges that
we're facing as a country including
the work that still needs to be done to
end systemic racism
and how the pandemic has affected our
mental health
you know we're still dealing with covet
and we're now going into year two and i
remember you wrote very candidly about
feeling a low grade of depression how
did you get through that and how did
that manifest itself for you
i think a lot of people felt that well
and that's why i thought it was
important to say it out loud because
to not feel depressed um with all that
was going on
it would be what's wrong with you it's
sort of like so you feel okay
in all of this you know and sometimes we
just need to speak the truth
you know when there is such uncertainty
and unrest
and and and lack of leadership and calm
it is upsetting um it it shakes you
but the point is is that you know there
are dips ebbs and flows to life there
are times when you feel
great and times when you feel really low
um
but it's important for us to to own that
that happens to us for me
you know i have developed my own set of
tools number one
i tell you this all the time sometimes i
have to turn it off
yeah that sometimes i cannot continue to
take it in not that still tell me that
yeah
when i'm on the tournament i have to
turn it off and i think i want
young people to be comfortable with
identifying
those peaks and valleys and knowing that
those those
those valleys don't last forever don't
last always and i just
i just don't want any young person to
make a decision about
anything when they're in a valley you
know
they have to know that time will will
move you to a better place
it does seem like we're coming out of
the cobit valley you know we
you know we're it was a long dark tunnel
i think we're still sort of
in the tunnel but i do sort of see light
back there yeah well it would be
better people would get vaccinated
there's still so many people that
you are either scared or just think no
i'm not doing it
all i can say is that i i have tried to
live a life where i don't lie to people
and the science behind a vaccine is the
same science
that's behind aspirin and insulin what
are the covert rules for visiting the
obamas
uh now it's be vaccinated
get your vaccine get get all of it
finish it up
and then we can talk so i urge everybody
out there
uh within the sound of our voices please
please get the vaccine
it's time the pandemic is not the only
challenge the country is facing
as we near the one-year mark since
george floyd's murder
there is an urgent call across the
nation to address systemic racism
and in particular the continued reports
of black people dying at the hands of
the police
there is clearly issues between the
black community and policing
and it seems there are still so many
people that don't want to even admit
that there's a problem with racism in
this country
yeah i wish i had an answer um
you know for for me it goes back to
we we have to get to know each other and
so much of what is going on is that if
you've been raised to
assume that all black people are ex
in the case of of interactions with
black men
and police officers sadly it can also
all often lead
to death you know after the derek chovan
verdict you and barack released a
statement that i thought was very
powerful
you all felt the need to speak out and
you don't often speak out the two of you
together the goal is to let leaders lead
but in in certain times people
you know look to us often well what do
you think how do you feel
um and we know that while we're all
breathing a sigh
of relief over the verdict there's still
work to be done
um and so we we can't sort of say great
that happen let's move on i know that
people in the black community
don't feel that way because they many of
us still
live in fear as we go to the grocery
store or worry about
our dogs walking our dogs or allowing
our children to get a license i mean
just imagine
you know you have aren't your girls
driving they're driving but every time
they get in a car by themselves
i worry about what assumption is being
made by somebody who doesn't know
everything about them the fact that they
are good students
and polite girls but maybe they're
playing their music a little loud maybe
somebody sees the back of their head
and makes an assumption i like so many
parents black kids have to that the the
innocent act of getting a license puts
fear in our hearts sasha and malia who
were only seven
and ten years old when the obamas
entered the white house
are both now in college with malia all
set to graduate
this year malia is graduating can you
just tell me how you guys are feeling
about that i remember
i remember when you were taking her to
school i know
i almost forgot that this year this
summer they're gonna be 23 and 20.
i mean i'm just like stop there i don't
even have teenagers anymore yes you have
young women
young women so i am excited for her next
chapter
that's why i want to be as excited as
every parent i don't want to have to
worry about
her entering a world where she has to
worry about
how people would treat her because of
the color of her skin
so i i am excited but i'd like to be
more excited
to know that as she goes out and gets
her first apartment
and rides the subway somewhere that they
don't make assumptions about her
based on the color of her skin that
she's not at risk out there
in the world as an adult because she's a
black woman
wow yeah michelle obama i thought very
candid talking you know when they were
in the white house they very seldom
talked about the girls yeah now you know
we're at a different time in the country
now
i think that she wanted to speak up
about it you know it's hard to believe
that they're 23 and 20.
i still remember them on the stage
coming out so that's something
it shows we're all getting older and
then the obama's got very sad news over
the week and i was so sad when i saw it
on the news at bo
we all remember when they got bo that's
right bo the family dog there he is
bo the family dog passed away over the
weekend and she
michelle obama released a statement beau
died of cancer
she said the past year with everyone
home under the roof no one was happier
than bo
to have all of his people under one roof
just the way he did the way
just the way he was the day we got him
we'll be grateful for the time that they
spent together
but we'll miss him the joyful life the
snuggles the games of fetch
and evening spent lying on the couch
michelle spent a lot of time taking care
of boa i have to say
but they all he was a family dog
everybody loved him and that was anybody
who's had a dog knows that
that's a huge it hurts it's a big loss
it hurts
we will have more of our conversation
with the former first lady in our next
hour
this is the reason why she did the
interview to begin with she discusses
her latest initiative
to give families access to healthy food
and tells us about a new
hobby yep she's found time for a hobby
that she's picked up during this
pandemic